welcome mr. and mrs. Trump for the
moment he landed Donald Trump was being
smothered with Indian hospitality a bear
hug from his host
a barrage of folk music and so welcoming
and for a president who loves rallies a
very big one if not quite the 10 million
people he claimed he been promised this
is the country where your people cheer
on some of the world's greatest cricket
players from su Ching Tendulkar to Virat
Kohli even mangling the name of one of
India's sporting legends Sachin
Tendulkar didn't detract from what was a
love in between two right-wing
nationalist leaders that is so much that
we shattered
shared values and ideals India's rise as
a prosperous and independent nation is
an example to every nation all over the
world you have done it as a tolerant
country and you have done it as a great
free country
never mind that critics say those
freedoms have been undermined by
Narendra Modi both leaders accused of
anti-muslim immigration policies and
divisive rhetoric sought to know what
the obscene Mahatma Gandhi would have
made of a millionaire president during
his ashram toying with a spinning wheel
but Donald Trump was basking in the
attention at the Taj Mahal he and the
first lady walked in the footsteps of
other famous couples with the backdrop
India's iconic shrine to eternal love
whether all the adoration the
president's been given on this trip
translates into something more tangible
we'll see tomorrow when the two leaders
sit down for talks after months of trade
disputes and when Trump's host hopes for
a return on 36 hours of unbridled
flattery
Dominic Waghorn Sky News